how are you doing good great
congratulations on this film it's just
such a it's such an important film and
you put in such a gorgeous performing
let's not say congratulations on things
but something I'm very interested in is
that's a very um internal performance is
a very quiet drama performance I'm
wondering what the key is to drawing out
these big emotions when most of them
happen below the surface I think the the
key for me was in studying the book
because the book is I think if you want
you look at the photos of Garrett at the
time and you own look you can see
something's wrong but he kind of you
really can't tell exactly what so it
could be anything that's a matter but
when I get to look at the book I see
specifically what's going on and and I
just took a lot of inspiration from that
because you're right it is hard to tell
a story through through mostly listening
that's like that was one of my biggest
one of the biggest challenges of this
product and I turned to the book a lot
it's interesting that you mentioned next
I was wondering if there's anything
specific from the book any any passage
or anything one specific thing that sort
of stuck in the back of your mind
throughout the entire project yeah I
think he describes at one point the
experience of walking into a room and
that he felt as though he had like
brought in some like dark energy or some
like there was some there was something
that that people would turn and look at
him and see that there was something
wrong with him that that to me was like
the the epitome of the character is that
that little moment so you were you were
born and raised in Brooklyn and in your
parents were both artists they were
writers and actors which is about as far
removed from from yes I was life it's
possible I'm wondering how you managed
to immerse yourself in just the the
everything around the character the the
where he lived that the society is in it
yeah well you know I think I do try to
do as much as work as as much work as
possible but when Russell Crowe arrives
on set and when it's my first time to do
a scene with him and I've never met him
before it there is an air of
deep and timid like intimidation that
comes up which I think is everything I
really need as an actor in that moment
and I find that all the true gems that
the things that really live in the film
are what's happening immediately in that
moment you know I I can do all the
research like I want and need but at the
end of the day it's whatever goes on in
front of the camera hmm I'm interested
in you mentioned that that first scene
with Russell Crowe I'm wondering which
what it was and what it was like just
somewhat insignificant scene were were
in the kitchen it's the first time I
think you meet him and I asked if I can
sleep over at my girlfriend's house and
I just remember like all the air like
was like sucked at like the second he
stepped in I was like I don't know it
was just like everyone became obsessed
with how to take care of Russell and I
was just like I don't know I didn't know
how to how to ask for what I needed in
that moment it's not that he was being
needy it was just that everybody wanted
to please him mm-hmm
I've seen you say that you you really
zeroed in on Jared's journey of
self-acceptance I'm wondering if you
could sort of explain a little and what
you what you did relate to in that part
of the character yeah
well I see myself as a very weird person
somebody who like most for the most part
has been described as I don't know I
feel like I'm not saying my life is like
some crazy life where I've been like
abused by people but I do feel like when
a lot of people get to know me they
they're surprised by how weird I am and
I feel like a lot of it's still really
hard for me to fully like own mass the
the aspects of myself like how I dance
and how I my sense of humor and this is
this story in its own way how help it
helps me with that and helps me stop
trying to cater to all the people around
me who don't don't seem to have any
interest in my weirdness I guess you
know interesting because I was wondering
a few if you if you saw if you were
aware of that parallel throughout the
process or even if it sort of yeah I
remember Jared's
that one of the reasons why he was most
excited that I was gonna do this movie
is that I was a weirdo he told me fair
fair and I think he really the last
thing he wanted was somebody who there's
who and who inherent you know it's easy
for me to play the part of somebody who
fits in but genuinely I'm very different
and and he and I suppose everyone is but
I feel it in particular with myself and
and he really didn't want somebody who
could just coast through somebody who
had something different about them and I
also recently saw something in any of
you did we said when you're doing stuff
like this sort of that the press and
talking about your films and you're sort
of trying on different hats you're sort
of still figuring out what kind of yeah
I'm wondering if that if you think at
all that that's helped you as an actor
just sort of yeah yeah definitely I
don't um I really don't I still don't
entirely know what group it is I belong
in like with respect to Frank I have so
many different friend groups that that
represents so many different you know
it's like so many different kinds of
ways of living and I think it definitely
serves me it doesn't is in that respect
it doesn't feel like any one project is
more me than the next you know they all
feel like an expression of Who I am and
they all feel like worlds that can
contain all of me and yet and a part of
me at the same time when you're when
you're playing a character and this
isn't direct you know copy of the memoir
it's not it's not you're not playing a
kite it's that version of the character
but I'm wondering if it when it's
something based on a real person story
how do you put a part of you into the
character how do you avoid just being a
straight copy of a real person well I
think it's kind of if I if I think would
be pretty impressive if I could just be
a straight copy of him if I could do
that understand Impressionists that
would be pretty great I don't know how
to do that mmm I only know how to to do
it from me so if anything that's like
speaks to my it speaks as much to my
lack of an ability
to copy him as much as it does to my
lack of desire to copy him like I don't
know how to do that
you